abone ol
[Alkış]
e Herkese merhabalar bu çocuk gel
hayatımın en heyecanlı konuşmasını
yapıyor olabilirim Şu ana kadar 400'ün
üzerinde konuşmam var ama hiç bu kadar
heyecanlanmıştım iki saattir dua
ediyorum Umarım bir şey olur iptal olur
diye ama gördüğünüz gibi olmadı ve
aranızdayım Öncelikle palex Giresun
Üniversitesi'nin düzenlediği için bu
kadar değerli bir ekibe Teşekkür
ediyorum Sonra 11 konuşmacıyım Benden
önceki birbirinden değerli on konuşmacı
teşekkür ediyorum onlardan sonra
konuşmak gerçekten zor iş bir kısmını
dinleye bildim ve elimden gelen en iyi
performans göstermeye çalışacağım
abone ol
bu ekibe sonsuz teşekkürler onları da
paylaştık istediğimde var bizde çok
güzel ağladılar VPN Ben de
hepsini tek tek teşekkür ediyorum
konuşmayı annemle babamı hitap ediyorum
Bu yıl benim için biraz zor geçti Mart
ayında Babamı sonra haziranın de annemi
kaybettim ve bir konuşma tamam mı Üstüne
geldi de yüz yüze yaptığım ilk konuşma o
nedenle adları bir yerde kalsın diye
onları paylaşmak istedim
Bu markayı silikonu diyoruz Genelde
insanlar bana bunu söylüyorlar marka
yeni bir konu diye bu konuda yaradığını
söyleyebilirim bazı araştırmalar diyor
ki ilk markalama örneklerini milattan
önce 5000 de görüyoruz yani bundan 7000
yıl önce ayırt edici ayrıştırıcı olarak
mağara duvarlarında varlar hayvanları
işaretlemek için kullanılmış onların
üzerinde varlar geliyoruz Bin yıl bir
yıl bu tarafa doğru
çömleklerde var tuğlalar da var
kiremitlerde var heryerde kullanıyoruz
Peki ben bunu anlattıktan sonra ikinci
öldüm Anne geliyor abi biz de gelip onu
diyorlar bizde Peki yeğenime Hayır biz
de öyle değil
1871'de ilk kanunumuz var alametifarika
nizamnamesi var yüzelli yıllık konu
bizde bizde de geri değil ama derseniz
diye biz de yeni yeni popüler olmaya
başladı
11.30 yılı var 30'lu Önce benimle aynı
mesleği yapan büyüklerim anlatmaya
başladılar ve peşlerinden biz geldik
Türkiye'nin 66 şehrinde 400'den fazla
konuşmada 150 binden fazla insana
Türkiye'den dünya markaları çıkardık
gelirsek marka nedir burada kırma
anlatmayacak kesinlikle işte marka Şudur
budur demiyorum marka aslında bir
anlayıştır bir felsefedir en başta
çıktığında benzer iki şeyi birbirinden
ayırt etmek üzere ortaya çıkan marka
zaman içerisinde öyle bir yüklendi ki
bir felsefeye dönüştü bir değerler
malzemesi haline geldi bir kurumdaki
bütün insanları kapısıdır paydaşları
yani müşterileri kapsadığı tüketicileri
kapsadı ve şimdi karşımızda
inanılmaz büyük bir marka diye bir konu
geldi
bu ve en önemlisi bir değer yaratma
işidir marka Peki Türkiye'den dünya
markaları çıkar derken veya çıkar mı
diye sorarken Sizce Dünya markası ne
demek
geldiğimizde bu soruyu defalarca sordum
herkesin aklında sabit bir şey var diyor
ki dünya coğrafyasının çoğunda satılan
veya üretilen veya herkesin bildiği
dünya İnsanların büyük bir çoğunluğunun
bildiği markalardan bahsediyorlar ama
emin miyiz değiliz aslında bu bizim
aldığımız gelin İsterseniz izlediğiniz
kadar Türkiye'nin dört bir köşesini
gidelim biz de dünya markaları var mı
bir incelersek
ama biz de dünya markası yok diyorlar
kesinlikle yanıldıklarını söyleyebilirim
var ve Türkiye'nin her yerini gezdim
gelin Ticaret odalarının Sanayi
odalarına gidelim organize sanayi
bölgelerine gidelim dünyanın dört bir
tarafında ürün satan o kadar fazla
markamız var ki ama biraz önce
anlattığımız duymuyor değil mi beni
dünyadaki herkesin bildiği dersek bu
konuda büyük markalarımız var ama zaman
içerisinde bunu geliştireceğimiz den çok
eminim değer yaratmak dedik ya marka
Peki o zaman değerleri odaklanmak lazım
Türk halkının değerlerine odaklanalım
Türkiye'nin toprağa Akın toprağa başlı
başına bir markadır Dünyada hiçbir
örneği olmayan bütün iklimleri bir arada
yaşayan her şeyi istisnasız yetiştiği Üç
tarafı denizlerle çevrili idi Yok yok
olan bir toprağın üstünde yaşıyoruz bu
Türkiye'nin toprağı kadar toprağın altı
da üstü de bu değerlerde doludur gelin
birlikte bakalım gidin Türkiye'nin gene
dört bir köşesine Toprağın üstünde her
şey yetişir bulunduğumuz coğrafyada şu
an bulunduğumuz yerde
fındığından çayına biraz Aşağı inin Kay
ısısına incirine her şeyi
yetiştirdiğimiz bir toprağın üstünde
yaşıyoruz toprağı üşenmeyin beş metre
kazıp kazdınız heryerden bir tarihi eser
çıkar toprağın üstüne gidin gezin doğal
güzelliği tarihi eserleri her yerde
vardır Dünyanın hiçbir ülkesinde
olmadığı kadar
ve gelelim insanına
hiçbir insan hiçbir kadın hiçbir
milletin kadını
Türk milletinin kadını kadar fedakâr
değildir Kurtuluş Savaşı'nı Türk
kadınları sayesinde kazandık diğer
herkes de birlikte aynı şekilde bu
topraklar için çaba sarf ettiler
sorumluluk yüklemek üzere ilk önce
gençlerimize sonra kadınlarımıza büyük
bir iki düşüyor onlara güveniyoruz
bizden dünya markaları çıkar
Çanakkale gidin bin 915 10 altına
toprağımızın altında neler olduğunu
göreceksiniz 15 yaşındaki çocuklardan 60
yaşındaki amcaları teyze ne kadar
binlerce Şehit orada ve bunları neden
anlatıyorum Türk milletinin değerleri
çoktur Eğer Birileri size Türkiye'den
dünya markaları çıkmaz derler Ben hiçbir
zaman sorgulamayı gerçekten çıkar
bu İstanbul'a gidelim de öyle bir şehir
yok
iyi bakın napolyon'a sormuşlar dünya bir
ülke olsaydı başkenti neresi olur
demişler İstanbul demiş ki bunu sadece
İstanbul özelinde söylemiyordu
Türkiye'nin 81 iline ait her birinin
başka bir değeri var Eğer marka yaratmak
Türkiye'den dünya markaları çıkarma Eğer
değere dayalı ysa Biz de o değerden çok
var peki
dünya markaları çıkardık da bize
faydasını bunun derseniz size çok şey
anlatabilirim bir
biz dışarıda gördüğümüz o dünya markası
dediğimiz markalar gibi çok sayıda marka
yarattığımız düşünelim
heryere satacağız bir maddi açıdan da
manevi açıdan da inanılmaz tahmin edecek
bizi Türk'ü ürünü her yerde olacak
istihdam yaratacak ekonomimizi
güçlendirecek ve
hepinize bir şekilde katkı sağlayacak
bu peki ne yapmamız lazım Bunun için
dersek
ve hep birlikte inanacağız Ben 150 bin
kişi Onda da bildim burada sizlere
aktarmaya çalışıyorum ve bu videoyu
izleyecek herkese arttırıyorum ki her
Türk vatandaşı hepimize görev düşüyor
tek tek bunu herkese anlatacağız bizden
Türkiye'den dünya markaları çıkacak
çıkarmamız lazım O kadar çok sayıda
çıkarmamız lazım ki bunun her
birbirimize 85000000 un her bir ferdine
faydası olacağından emin olabilirsiniz
Eğer Bunu anlatabilir seksek bizler için
bunu başarmak çok kolay
bu peki Nasıl yapacağız
Ben her zaman işimizi elimizden gelenin
en iyisi şekilde yapacağız yani hangi
görevde olursanız olun isterseniz iki
kağıdı birbirine yapıştırdım bakın onu
bile elimizden gelenin en iyisini
yapacağız işimizin ayrıntılarını özen
göstereceğiz ve en iyisi derken
tekrarlıyorum elimizden gelenin en
iyisini yapacağız ve buna bir değer
yaratma işi olarak bakacağız ve Made in
Turkey logosu hepiniz biliyorsunuzdur
neydi torpil olsun Made In Turkey logosu
görsel anlamda hiçbir şey ifade etmez
aslında ne zaman ifadeler biliyor
musunuz Eğer bir ürün üstüne Made in
Turkey logosu bastığımızda o ürünün daha
değerli kılan biliyorsak veya tercih
sebebi yapabiliyorsan O zaman o Made In
Turkey logosu çok daha kıymetli hale
gelecek neyle olur bu
arkasındaki iyi şeyleri yaratmakta olur
nedir Bu iyi şeyler
Türkle iş yapmak değildir tüp yapıyorsa
iyi yapar Türk ettik davranır Türkçe
ticaret yapmak keyiflidir Türk'ün
yaptığım al sağlamdır dayanıklıdır
dedirte biliyorsak O da yangının değeri
b143 çıkacak Peki Sizce mümkün mü
Bunu yapmamız mümkün mü
ne
kadarlık mümkün den daha güçlü bir
mümkün bekliyorum
üçüncü eğitim o zaman son sözler
aranızdan ayrılacağım Atatürk ne demiş
vatanını en çok seven görevini en iyi
yapandır teşekkür ederim